I'm Jordan Ellenberg mathematician let's
answer some questions from the internet
this is geometry
[Music]
support at s39 gsy asks who the f
created geometry nobody created geometry
geometry was always there it's just part
of the way we interact with the physical
world the person who first codified it
and formalized it was somebody named
uclid who lived in North Africa around
2,000 years ago and we also know that a
lot of what he wrote down was the work
of a lot of other people that he was
collecting and putting in written form
but this idea of geometry is this set of
formal rules we Ed to carefully put
together demonstrations of facts about
angles triangles circles Etc that's when
it sort of stops being purely intuitive
and starts being something we can put in
a book alien Searcher asks new shapes
are just discovered yes absolutely new
shapes are just discovered all the time
one of the big misconceptions about math
that people have is that math is f
finished people who are geometers are
typically thinking about crazy stuff
that's going on in high Dimensions with
all kinds of crazy curvature but
four-dimensional shapes are in some
sense just as real as three-dimensional
shapes we just have to kind of train our
minds to be able to perceive what shapes
in those Dimensions like a hypercube or
a tesseract would look like inkbot
Kowalski asked wait wait a tesseract is
a real thing definitely yes a Tess Act
is another name for what's usually
called in math a Cube MCU did not create
the idea of the Tesseract being in
Popular Science Fiction that really
comes in in meline langel's book A
Wrinkle in Time all right here you have
a square a two-dimensional figure and
here you have its three-dimensional
counterpart a cube a cube you can think
of as two squares the top square and the
bottom square and then you sort of
connect them together if the cube is the
three-dimensional figure and the square
is the two-dimensional figure what would
be the four-dimensional figure I guess
the hyper Cube would have to be
something that was two cubes joined
together and it would have to have twice
as many corners as the cube does or 16
and now I've got to connect Each corner
of the little Cube to the corresponding
corner of The Big Cube this is our
picture of the hyper Cube and now you
may say like are there really four
dimensions or is that just an invention
well you know what when we do regular
geometry we're working in a perfectly
flat plane does that exist in the real
world like probably not as a physical
object the two-dimensional plane or
threedimensional space are just as much
of an abstraction as four-dimensional
space okay claudo jacobo asks if algebra
is the study of structure what is
geometry algebra is the logical and
symbolic right it's that side of your
brain geometry is different geometry is
physical geometry is Primal and like
doing mathematics makes use of this
tension between the algebraic side of
our mind and the geometric side three
Omega 2 asks how can I use the
Pythagorean theorem to solve my problems
in life look I'm going to be honest with
you I can't quite imagine what problem
you might have in your life that would
be solved by the Pythagorean theorem the
problem that the Pythagorean theorem
solves is the following one if for some
reason I have some distance I want to
Traverse and if I know how far west you
have to go to get there and then how far
north and I happen to know these two
distances then the Pythagorean theorem
allows you to compute this diagonal
distance which we call C but we can also
write it as the square root of a 2 + b 2
is this the problem you're facing in
your everyday life if it is you're in
luck the Pythagorean theorem is here for
you but in most cases it is not TM San
asks what is special about a pringle's
hyperbolic paraboloid geometry the
Pringle is a wonderful geometric form
what's special about it is this point
right here at the center of the Pringle
if I move from left to right I can't
help but go up so it seems like I'm at
the bottom of the Pringle but if I move
from front to back back I can't help but
go down from the center so it's somehow
simultaneously at the top it's a peak
and a valley at the same time and this
special kind of point which is called a
saddle point in math is what gives the
Pringle its particularly Charming
geometry Dr Funky spoon asks sucker MC's
maintain cool Under Pressure but who
with geometry like MC eer what a good
question MC eer beloved artist of all
matthy people was famous for studying
and using in his art what are called
tessellations ways of taking a flat
plane and covering it with copies it was
something he learned actually in part
from hanging out with the alra this
incredible Palace from Islamic Spain
when you go to the alra you see these
incredibly intricate but also very
repetitive figures which by repetition
across the entire wall it becomes very
complicated and Rich that's the feature
of a Tessellation who with geometry like
mcer the answer is the UN named
architects of the alra in Granada Spain
Raspberry Pi asks how many holes are
there in a straw fortunately I always
bring a straw with me wherever I go how
many holes are there in it there are the
one holers who feel that well look
there's like one hole it goes all the
way through like what more is there to
say and there are the two holers whose
view is there's a hole at the top of the
straw and there's a hole at the bottom
of the straw for the people who think
there's two holes I would say imagine
this straw if you can getting shorter
and shorter like imagine I sort of cut
it and it was half a long and I cut it
again until it's so short that it's
actually like shorter than the distance
around a little bit like this does this
have one hole in it or two how many
holes does a bagel have in it that's
basically the same shape as this if you
say a bagel has two holes I think we all
agree that would be like a very weird
thing to say about a bagel so now I'm
talking to you triumphant one H holders
if you think this straw is one hole
let's say I take it and I pinch the
bottom like this how many holes are
there in it now there's just like the
one hole at the top I mean you could
fill this with water right it's
basically
a bottle how many holes are there in the
water bottle just the one at the top
that you drink out of right but if it
has one hole now and I poked a hole in
the bottom and I opened up the bottom
how many holes would it have it's got to
have two right I think the way to think
about the straw is that yeah there's two
holes but one of them is the negative of
the other top hole plus bottom hole
equals zero that sounds like an insane
thing to say both the one holers and two
holers are right in a way as long as
they're willing to learn about the
arithmetic of holes liberated Soul asks
the golden ratio in art photography is
that something to do with perfect
composition yes the golden ratio is very
popular it's a number a kind of
unassuming number it's about
1.618 and there have always been people
who felt that this particular number had
some kind of mystical properties why
that number well one way of describing
it is that if I have a rectangle whose
length and width are in that proportion
a so-called golden rectangle it has has
a special property which is that if I
cut the rectangle to make one part of it
a square what's left is again a golden
rectangle no other kind of rectangle has
that property some people would say like
you can find it in nature like for
instance I have here the shell of some
kind of EMB bird braid like a wel in
here we could find the golden ratio they
say you can find it in a pine cone or I
mean I think its mystical significance
has been much overrated so I don't want
to sound too salty about this but I
think you shouldn't look to it to
improve your Stockport P folio help you
lose weight or help you find the
prettiest rectangle zohi rafik 83 asks
why are Honeycombs hexagons one thing I
can tell you is that when the bees build
the Honeycombs they're not hexagons they
actually build them round and then
something forces them into that
hexagonal shape so there's a lot of
controversy about this for instance why
hexagons and not a grid of squares or
triangles and there are people who will
say well there's an efficiency argument
maybe this is the way to give the
honeycomb structural Integrity using the
least amount of material I'm not sure
that's completely convincing but that's
at least one theory that people have
bibbit e asks how are there so many
different types of triangles this
actually speaks to kind of a deep
division in math the so-called three
body problems one of the hardest
problems in mathematics with two points
you're making a line segment that looks
like this and there's not a lot of
variety among line segments they're all
basically the same three points totally
different story triangles come in an
infinite variety of variations I mean
you could have one that's like very
narrow like this you could have one
that's nice and symmetric our friend the
equilateral triangle like that you could
have a right triangle with a nice right
angle I could just keep on drawing
triangles in this little board and each
one would look different from all the
others and that is the difference
between two and three problems involving
two points simple problems involving
three points already a completely
infinite variety Tac 16 asks what is the
random walk Theory and what does it mean
for investors imagine a person with no
sense of purpose every day they wake up
and they walk a mile in One Direction or
another you could track that person's
motion over a long period of time that
purposeless mindless unpredictable
process a lot of people think the stock
market basically works pretty much like
that this is something that was worked
out actually a really long time ago
around 1900 by Lou bashel he was
studying bond prices trying to
understand what are the forces that
govern these prices and yeah this would
have been incredible Insight which is to
say what if those prices just every day
they might happen to go up or they might
happen to go down purely by random
chance and what he found is that if you
model prices that way it looks exactly
like the prices in real life vicam punt
asks can you believe you can take the
circumference of any Circle and divide
it by its diameter and you will always
get exactly Pi yeah I totally believe
that and in fact I would say I relish it
because it's one of the things that
makes Circle circles there's really only
one kind of circle it could be small
or it could be big but this one is just
a scaled up version of this one Whatever
the diameter of this circle is and this
guy has a diameter too if this diameter
is seven times as big as this one then
also this circumference that's the total
distance around the circle is 7 times
the size of this one so in particular
the ratio between the circumference and
the diameter is the same in both cases
and that constant ratio Pi it's about
3.1415 I don't care so much what pi is
is to 10 decimal places or 20 decimal
places mathematically what's important
is that there is such a thing as Pi that
there is a constant that governs all
circles no matter how big or how small
tasking hanza asks what is the worst
section in maths and why is it ukian
geometry okay that stings a little bit
geometry is the cilantro of math
everybody either loves it or hates it
it's the only part of math where you're
asked to prove that something is true
rather than just getting the answer to a
question ukian geometry is geometry of
the plane there's lots of other
geometries non- ukian geometries you
guys probably know the fact that the sum
of the angles of a triangle is supposed
to be 180° and a uid world that's true
but on a curved surface like a sphere
that's totally wrong all right my lines
are not as straight as they might be but
if you look at this kind of bulgy
triangle and it's three angles their sum
is going to be around 270 like way
bigger than 180 and that's a
fundamentally nonukan phenomenon that
can only happen in a curved space we now
know thanks to Einstein that space
actually is curved when he
revolutionized physics in the beginning
of the 20th century the miracle is that
non- ukian geometry was already there
for him to use the mathematicians had
already understood how curved space
could work well in time for Einstein to
realize that the world we actually live
in is like that wion cmk asks Inception
is it really a thesis on manifold and
geometry and four-dimensional space
Inception is a little bit more like what
we call in geometry of fractal which has
the property that it's self-similar that
if you zoom in on it you see a smaller
replica of the whole thing the more you
zoom in the more detail you see and that
seems to me the sort of spirit of the
movie Inception so I I think I'm going
to call that a fractal movie think big
kids asks is there any better way to
teach transformational geometry than
original Nintendo Tetris I spend way too
much time playing Tetris in college so
I've thought about it a lot tried to
make excuses for why that was actually a
productive use of my time if you a
modern geometry class it's not just
about angles and circles and shapes they
also talk about Transformations they say
what happens if you take this shape and
reflect it or take this shape and rotate
it Tetris teaches you that skill imagine
this little dude like marching down the
screen you have to very quickly mentally
figure out what it's going to look like
rotated and which version of it is going
to fit into a space where you need it
and so I think you can think of Tetris
as like a very very efficient in
somewhat stressful training device for
exactly that mental rotation skill that
we're now trying to teach kids in
Geometry Maris Crabtree has a joke for
me a mobia strip walks into a bar
sobbing the bartender asks what's wrong
buddy the mobia strip replies where do I
even begin You' think in my profession
You' think I would have heard all the
math jokes there are but every once in a
while I hear a new one so amobia strip
is a gric figure with a rather unusual
quality that's not visible to the naked
eye which is that it only has one side
I'm going to Mark a little spot with an
X and now I'm going to take my finger
put it on the X and I'm going to start
moving my way around the band watch me
very closely I'm not switching sides I'm
moving I'm moving my finger is staying
on the
band and look where I am I'm sort of in
the same spot but I'm on the other side
somewhat miraculously what appeared to
be two different sides of the band are
actually connected Rebecca
57219 asks anyone currently in a
position where you use Pascal's triangle
I definitely use Pascal's triangle and
the numbers in it all the time here I
have one with me there's these numbers
written in the form of a triangle and
the rule if you wanted to make one of
these yourself is just that each number
is the sum of the two numbers above it
so right see how this six is the sum of
three and three and then if I didn't
know what went in here I could look
above it and see a four and a six oh
those add up to 10 so I have to put a 10
there but the cool thing is that these
numbers actually mean something actually
they mean a lot of different things but
one of my favorite things that they mean
is they record the likelihood of various
outcomes in a random scenario like
flipping coins so how do you turn these
numbers into probabilities well if you
were to add up all six of these numbers
you would get 32 so you should really
think of these numbers as fractions like
one out of 32 5 out of 32 10 out of 32
those fractions are probabilities if I
flip a coin five times there's six
things that can happen I can get zero
heads one head two heads three heads
heads four heads okay well I I ran out
of fingers but or five heads that's a
sixth possibility and those correspond
exactly to these six numbers in the
fifth row of Pascal's triangle if you
did an experiment and you flipped five
coins thousands and thousands of times
the proportion of those times that you
would get two heads out of five would
converge to 10 out of 32 harpa 71 burner
asks why does the shape of a district
matter and I'm going to assume that the
question here is about congressional
districts the reason is that if you see
one with a very strange shape that is an
indication that someone has designed
that district for a political purpose
I'm sorry to say that like rather
Advanced mathematical techniques are
used in order to effectively explore
that geometric space to find the most
partisan advantage that you can squeeze
out of a map legislators choosing their
voters instead of the voters choosing
their legislators so that's why we care
pw11 one1 okay I don't know how many
ones there are there's a lot of ones why
do GPS systems need to use geometry
based on a sphere in order to work what
GPS essentially does is there's a bunch
of satellites which are in positions
that we know they can tell you what is
your distance when you're somewhere on
the Earth from each one of those
satellites and knowing those numbers is
actually enough to specify your exact
location let's say I know I'm exactly
5,342 km from a given satellite the set
of all points that are at exactly that
distance from the satellite is a sphere
whose Center is that satellite that's
what the definition of a sphere is it's
the set of all points at a fixed
distance from a given Center if I have
two satellites I'm at the intersection
of two spheres once you have four or
more of those spheres they're never
going to have more than one point in
common that's exactly the geometry that
underlies GPS Quantum stat asked what
can the geometry of deep learning
networks tell us about their inner
workings I'm going to tell you the
strategy that it uses it's basically a
very intensive form of trial and error
we make sort of some modest change to
our behaviors and sort of see if it
gives us better results and if it does
we keep doing that thing I think of that
as a kind of exploration of a space
geometry in the modern sense is any
context in which we can talk about
things being near and far we know what
it means for two people to be near each
other geographically similarly the space
of all strategies for recognizing a face
those have geometries too there are some
strategies that are near each other and
some that are far away any context in
which we can talk about near and far
whether that's the surface of the Earth
or a social network or your family where
you can talk about close relatives or
far relatives I know I'm kind of
sounding like I'm just saying geometry
as everything but I'm going to be honest
that is kind of what I think okay so
those are all the questions we have time
for today I hope my answers made some
sense or messed with your mind a little
or best of all maybe did some
combination to those two things thanks
for watching geometry
support